Let's spell out what this first term means --
(t + h + 1)³--
here comes the trick -- I write it as
((t + 1) + h) * ((t + 1) + h) * ((t + 1) + h).
I just reshuffled the different terms --
t + 1 + h, t + 1 + h and 3 factors of
that sort gives the 3rd power.
What do i get? (t + 1) * (t + 1) * (t + 1) = (t + 1)³.
Then I get terms of that sort--
h * (t + 1) * (t + 1),
h * (t + 1) * (t + 1) is, of course, (t + 1)².
How many terms of that sort do I get?
h * this one * this one is one of that sort.
(t + 1) * h * (t + 1);
second one, and (t + 1) * (t + 1) * h;
a third one, 3 terms of that type plus everything else has h² in it --
h * h * (t + 1) or (t + 1) * h * h
or even h * h * h,
So, whatever happens to appear next is the h² times something.
So what do we get?
1/h times -- (t + 1)³, (t + 1)³ cancels -- 3h(t + 1)² + h² times something.
And look what happens -- we divide by h,
h/h cancels, h²/h becomes h,
and in the end, we are left with 3(t + 1)², and this term is negligible.
So the answer would be 3(t + 1)².
Of course, you may already know that there's tons
of rules how to compute derivatives.
In the end, they're just shortcuts of such computations.